well the FBI doesn't seem to made a lot
of progress figuring out how the Biden
family made all that money from foreign
governments and was it legal or not but
Congressman James Comer Jamie Comer of
Kentucky has been looking into it as a
new committee chairman and he found that
Halle Biden the Widow of Beau Biden and
Hunter Biden's ex-girlfriend received a
000 cut of a three million dollar payout
from China it was part of a deal that
Hunter Biden
made associative Hunter Biden made with
the Chinese State Energy company Hunter
Biden's legal team come up with a
statement today and said quote Hunter is
a private citizen with every right to
pursue his own business Endeavors joined
several business partners in Seeking a
joint venture with a privately owned
legitimate Energy company in China so
that's his attorney's position Brandon
Divine is one of the world's experts on
this question she is the author of the
book laptop from Helen she joins us now
to assess
Miranda thank you so much for coming on
so um
what do you think Jamie Comer is going
to find here what do you think of Hunter
Biden's attorney's statement
thanks Tucker um well this is clearly
Hunter Biden's lawyers are trying to say
that this money these two tranches of
three million dollars that went to Rob
Walker Hunter Biden associate business
associate and friend
um was seed money was sort of prepayment
for future work to be done and that's
ridiculous Tony bobolinski has said and
he was involved in these deals uh Hunter
Biden's former business partner and
there's ample evidence on the laptop to
show that Hunter Biden and his business
partners were doing work for this
Chinese energy conglomerate for the last
two years of Joe Biden's vice presidency
they owed money and the money was not to
be paid until after Joe Biden left
office and so sure enough here we are in
February of uh 2017 just you know less
than two months after Joe Biden's left
office and the first of these three
million dollar payments has come through
to Rob Walker's bank account and then
another one came a couple of weeks later
and within a few days that money gets
disbursed
to we know from James coma today to four
immediate family members of Joe Biden
and that being his son Hunter his
brother Jim Biden Hallie Biden who's the
Widow of his late son Beau who at that
stage had been having a relationship
with Hunter for two years since her
husband had died and then there's
another fourth family member of the
bidens that James Comer in his oversight
committee have not yet been able to find
the identity of it's just named as Biden
but they are subpoenaing those bank
records that bank account and presumably
we'll find that pretty soon probably
early next week and you know they're
continuing on just following the money
and I think if if as Hunters lawyers and
the White House is saying there's
nothing untoward about this then why was
this money so
laboriously doled out over three months
in small increments to
various members of the family and why
was it given to Hallie Biden who was a
primary school teacher and did they all
pay tax on it and why was Rob Walker the
middleman
I I don't know I mean they didn't it's
not like they complained about a drag
queen Story Hour so the FBI isn't
actually interested apparently uh in
finding out what happened but I I hope
all of those questions are answered uh
by Mr Comer's committee Rainer Vine
thank you for that update tonight
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight